يستعد المدعي العام لمن هات
لدخول التاريخ كاول مدعي عام يوجه اتهامات
جنائيه لرئيس امريكي سابق
وعلى الرغم من حداثه شغله المنصب الا انه
وجد نفسه في موقف مثير للجدل فبين عشيه
وضحاها تحولت انظار الراي العام اليه بعد
اتهامات ترامب له والتي وصلت حد وصفه
باللبرالي الفوضوي
براج الديمقراطي بالتدخل في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بينما يفتخر مؤيدوه بموقفه حيث
اشادوا بصموده امام هجمات ترامب الدعائيه
وقال احد المحامين الفيدراليين ان براج
البالغ من العمر 49 عاما شخص قوي ليس من
السهل تغيير مبادئه ووفقا للسياسيين فان
براج يواجه مهمه ليست بالسهله
من هارلم بنيويورك حيث امضى طفولته تعرض
لمحاولات اغتيال فاشله ست مرات وفقا لمجله
بوليتيكو
وقبل ان يتقلد منصبه اشرف على دعوى ضد
ترامب اسفرت عن دفع الرئيس السابق غرامه
قدرها مليون دولار
وبعد اكثر من عام من تعيينه اصبحت ترامب
هدفه الجديد
ورغم ان براج استطاع توطيد مكانته الا ان
قضيه ترامب سلطت الاضواء عليه ووضعته امام
اختبار صعب في كيفيه التعامل مع الازمه